[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
ryan nicodemus is out on vacation today
he'll be back with us next week via
phone for episode 356 and he'll be back
in studio for episode 357 but don't
worry we're joined by malabama and t.k
coleman today and coming up on this free
minimal episode we're joined by my wife
rebecca schern host of the how to love
podcast and we're talking to a listener
about kids stuff we also have an
outstanding lightning round listener tip
and added value segment for you you can
check out the full three hour maximal
edition of episode 355 where we answer
four times the questions and dive deep
into seven simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
alabama where you want to start today
let's start with our first question from
an anonymous listener in texas i come
from a blended family
my husband has a 12 year old daughter
from a previous marriage i have two
daughters from a previous marriage and
we have a daughter together
his daughter is very very
spoiled she's a really good kid very
well behaved
but the grandparents it's not even my
husband it's his mom and dad they just
over indulge her which is really hard
for
my kids to see when she every time she
comes home which she goes to their house
a lot
she has something new and just like oh
look what my grandma got and then of
course my kids are kind of sitting there
like oh well that's cool i didn't get
anything you know
i don't like that and i also just
because
i love and care about her too i don't
want her to become obsessed with
consuming and wanting to buy things i'm
trying to raise these girls to learn
that
that is not what's
important in life
and i'm not trying to be controlling i'm
not trying to step on their toes you
know i know i'm the new wife over here
and they've been doing things their way
for
a very long time she's been the only
grandchild until now and it's just
really hard to balance when there's four
kids involved and one of them is just
overindulged
i'm talking extravagant birthday gifts
and
my husband
it doesn't bother him
you know he kind of looks at it as
if she's happy if it makes my mom and
dad happy to buy this stuff you know i
don't see the problem
i just need to learn i guess how to
live with not letting it bother me and
that's what i'm struggling with because
i know i can't change things i can't
force people to
stop you know doing what they're doing
or you know but how do i
feel better about living in a house
where
it's just goes against all i want to do
for raising kids
and
i love my husband so much and
i will do anything to stay with him be
with him so obviously
i would never leave my husband because
of this problem but
is there anything i can do to make life
a little easier and for me to let go of
how i'm feeling about this
well damn my first bit of advice was to
leave your husband now
that's always my advice for bex by the
way leave your husband
just go just go
no in fact i don't have any advice i do
have some observations though and that's
what bex and i try to do with her
podcast how to love is
we call it how to love but that is an
intentional misnomer because there isn't
a seven step plan how to love someone
really a better name would be
understanding love and i think that's
really part of the caller's question
here
she said how do i not be bothered
and of course there isn't well here are
the three things you do to not be
bothered well first you do jumping jacks
then you stand on one leg for seven
minutes and if there was some sort of
mechanical recipe for that great it
would be so easy to give it to you but
what we're really talking about here is
understanding
the problem understanding what is
upsetting you understanding also the
boundaries that you may need to set up
and so here's something pithy for you
caller sincerity and candor
are the bricks and mortar that build
boundaries
what do i mean by that so first off
sincerity clearly there's some sincerity
here in your question you don't want to
approach the other people in your life
with whom you are setting up boundaries
in a passive aggressive way that is not
sincere that's how you tear down
boundaries let's say you tear down an
entire relationship that's how you
increase your own bother and you bother
them more with a
with some sort of passive aggressive
attitude toward the relationship but
then there's the other side of the
sincerity you can be sincere but you
also have to be candid you have to let
them know what your standards are
because if you don't
if you don't tell them
what your standards are then how can
they possibly know how can they know
that you feel as though it's being
overindulgent when they feel it's being
loving you have two different opinions
about the same thing here bex you have
any thoughts about this yeah yeah i mean
she mentions it's a relatively new
relationship
right yeah and so
you know benefit of the doubt is they
just don't understand where you're
coming from how you would like to live
your life how you would like to raise
your daughters
right or your children i didn't catch um
the
the new one the new edition
but
yeah it
so having the conversation being candid
right um
i think that that is a great first step
if you haven't done that already
um
another couple thoughts that came to
mind was like
how differently the different children
are being treated yes and how one of the
things that i really appreciated about
our relationship and especially with
respect to
ella our nine-year-old daughter is that
from day one when she was a year and a
half two years old you treated her as
your own yeah you referred to her as
your daughter
and
i mean even though
um presumably unlike this relationship
like you didn't want children like that
was never in the cards for you um and
yet we met and we fell in love and you
transferred that love onto ella and you
embraced her wholeheartedly and the
thing that i heard a couple different
times was like my kids versus his kids
and then our kid together
and it sounds like the grandparents have
also internalized that that sort of
separation that differentiation between
the different
children yes and maybe a thought is is
not only having the discussion around
um
the different
sort of expectations with respect to
stuff and experiences what and what not
being uh
unequally distributed between the
children but like
maybe just
here's how we would like to function as
a family not as individual
units of children or groupings of
children you know yeah so
getting everyone on the same playing
field right so to speak and then
building the boundaries from there
because it becomes really difficult if
you say well this kid has
these boundaries and so we can only do
this for this kid and we start
segregating all of our kids and treating
them differently
and pretending as though well you know
imagine if like ella does something
that i disagree with or i dislike she
does something i hate i don't all of a
sudden say look what your daughter has
done right no i'm also responsible here
and so because she lives in our house
with us
we are her parental figures right and so
all floating the blame
as opposed to what i love about what the
caller's question here she's trying to
take responsibility for the situation
she just can't figure out how right now
yeah so i have one thought and then a
question for the two of you with how you
deal with this with with ellie
so
when it comes to having that
conversation i thought that was a really
good suggestion it's a new relationship
maybe you all just haven't talked about
it and it's as simple as having a
conversation one thing i want to suggest
about the conversation is to
converse with specificity something that
i see a lot with coaching managing and
parenting is whenever we have a problem
with another person's behavior we tend
to give them abstract recommendations i
need you to be more mindful i need you
to be more punctual i need you to be
more considerate and that's very
abstract and it sort of just keeps
things in the realm of like nebulous
character traits that you think the
other person needs to develop
but it helps when you can be specific
instead of i need you to be more mindful
like hey
when you see your little sister in the
bathroom don't just barge in knock knock
first if you need to go in and wait for
a response right i need you to be more
punctual like hey out of consideration
for the team
i need you to be here 15 minutes before
starting time right the more you can you
know make your recommendations or your
requests in a specific way the more that
other person can look at it as something
concrete that they can act on or an easy
adjustment that they can make
the question i have
i hear this second issue
this issue of hey when he does something
for his child it bothers me because i
can't
or won't do the same for my child and
now my children might feel bad because
they're looking at another kid in the
family who gets to experience a
privilege that they don't
sometimes that's unavoidable sometimes
that's a part of life where you have to
sit there and watch your child
feel the sadness of seeing another kid
whether it's one of their cousins or
something like that get something that
they don't get how do you guys deal with
that in your family
i mean it's nice because ella's just a
child of one
right so within our family dynamic we
don't have that direct thing but she has
cousins she has great friends you know
that lead very different lives than than
we do and
yeah it is helping them learn to sit
with the discomfort of
comparison yeah right i think it's also
about seeing the benefits
so quite often it's like oh what i'm
hearing in this question is oh you know
what this kid doesn't have as many toys
as that kid and therefore it's perceived
to be bad i think ella quite often
perceives it as good and she understands
that there's no good or bad we often
have this conversation with her with
respect to like this toy isn't morally
good or bad and having more toys isn't
good having fewer toys quite often is
good she understands the benefits of the
extra space in fact we were trying to
decide the um what bed to put in her
room when we all sort of moved into
ventura county together we she she had a
queen size bed at one house and she had
a twin size bed at the other hey which
one do you want you want the big bed or
do you want the smaller one that gives
you more space i want more space in my
room she wants more openness she doesn't
see it as the void
as alan watts often talks about like
space just sort of
confers the material itself and so you
if you get more space it also sort of
honors or acknowledges the materials
that are there that's not to say she
doesn't have toys ella definitely has
toys ella owns more stuff than bex and i
do and that's okay right it's in her
boundaries her boundaries are we have
this
big dresser where all of her toys go and
we have a bookshelf where all of her
books go and if she needs more books
than that then she has to remove a book
because the boundary has already been
reached she needs more toys quite often
she'll go through her own toys now
without becks asking without me asking
and she'll say hey can we give this i'm
not playing with this anymore can i give
this to a kid
who might enjoy playing with it and oh
isn't that the best feeling because we
didn't tell her hey you should get rid
of this hey why aren't you grateful for
these things that you own no she sees it
through our own behavior repeatedly
well one of the other things that she
did relatively recently and maybe a sort
of related experience to the the
caller's experience is she does have two
separate households right she lives with
us for part of the year and she lives
with her father her biological father
for part of the year and her experience
in those two places is very different oh
yes um and recently we were talking uh
on facetime with her
and i don't remember how it came up josh
you might be able to uh refresh my
memory but
she ended up showing us her closet yeah
and it was just like
bubble like overflowing literally
overflowing out of her closet onto the
floor like there's just stuff everywhere
it was also figuratively overflowing she
you could see the anxiety
and the sort of madness
in her facial features and she looked at
us she said i would feel calmer
if i didn't have as much stuff in this
closet and so bex just asked her okay
well
are there some things in there you can
get rid of and she goes yeah let me see
and so we're on face time with her and
she starts without us telling because i
could tell her hey you know what ella
you need to declutter your closet no no
yeah bex just asked a question hey would
you feel calmer are there any things
that you might want to get rid of asking
questions is a far more effective way to
parent it's also an effective way to set
boundaries with the people around us
because you're not telling them no no no
you're not prescribing something you're
not being didactic you are simply asking
a question allows them to get to a
realization or a better understanding of
the things that are causing that anxiety
that stress that
oh that feeling that we have i got all
this stuff and it's causing all this
sort of emotional clutter inside me i
love that man you know so i mean you
know with this question i i always like
to think about solutions in terms of
what can i control
what's within my locus of control if if
my solution depends on me successfully
getting another person to change
then i'm bound to feel powerless
resentful and frustrated and it's not
that sometimes people don't owe us that
in some sense of the word but
you don't always get what other people
owe you
and so you have to have a game plan for
what do i do how do i live when other
people don't do right by me in the way
that i define right and i think the best
way to keep things in your locus of
control with respect to this situation
is decide how are you going to
communicate your values to your children
in a way that is resilient in the
presence of someone who lives with them
and has a different set of values you
know a belief isn't very powerful if it
needs everyone else to believe it in
order to be useful to you and so
something to teach children very early
on is how to hold their values in a
meaningful way without requiring the
rest of the world to agree with them
because if you need that you'll never be
able to last for 24 hours in this world
oh that was so good that's beautiful
caller i'm going to send you a copy of
ryan's in my last book it's called love
people use things because the opposite
never works so
well there's seven different chapters in
there about the seven different
essential relationships we have in our
lives our relationship with stuff our
relationship with ourselves our
relationship with money our relationship
with our values but the chapter i think
you'll find the most value and it's
actually my favorite chapter in the book
it's our relationship with people and
it's about
the sort of tension that we have with
other people that at first we want to
get rid of but often it's that tension
that makes us and the dynamics that we
have it makes us feel alive and so i
think you'll enjoy the audiobook version
if you like our podcast or if you want
the book book or the ebook version of
love people use things i'll be happy to
send those to you as well do you know
what time it is
it's time for the lightning round yes
indeed that's where we answer your text
messages
you can text your questions 937-202-4654
you see whatever question you want those
questions go right to my phone to ryan's
phone we answer folks directly we also
answer some questions here on the
podcast now you all probably know this
during the lightning round this is where
we answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we call them minimal maxims we
put them in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like today's
lightning round question is from emily
my four-year-old is comfortable with
letting go and practicing gratitude but
outside influences like preschool
classmates leave her wanting more how
can we demonstrate the benefits of
wanting less to young children
so
i was thinking about this with respect
to ella bex
the thing you want is never the thing
you want now we talked about that a
moment ago on the
private podcast it's always the idea the
dream behind the thing the belief behind
the thing
right and so with ella
getting her to understand the stories
that she tells herself about the things
that she might want
that is so
so powerful
because
ella
isn't holding on to the things when
she's holding on to something she's
holding on to the story about that thing
the robot that she has you know she has
a little remote control robot that she
barely ever played with but she told
herself some story that it might be fun
in some
ideal future
we found out the biggest problem with
that was she couldn't read the
instruction manual very well
and she had a friend a slightly older
friend come over who read the
instruction manual to her and all of a
sudden it opened up this whole world of
possibility so if i had told her hey you
need to let go of this robot
i would have simply just been making a
prescription a command a demand on her
and i've been eliminating all of the
critical thinking which is exactly what
our education system does right now as
well as a reason bex and i took
ella out of
public school recently and were
unschooling her even reading the book
which we'll talk about during our added
value segment
it's called weapons of mass instruction
and it's really about how we have
ruined critical thinking
within our children and so how does that
apply to
emily's question
my four-year-old is comfortable with
letting go and practicing gratitude but
outside influences like preschool
classmates schoolmates in general right
they uh leave her wanting more and so
what you're saying is the cultural
influences are disrupting or
interrupting
her natural tendency her willingness
to let go
when
the
buddhists talk about
nirvana they talk about breathing out
to letting go nirvana is just perpetual
letting go a state of
being comfortable with
letting go
and kids are comfortable with letting go
all the time because they're not
clinging to the past they're not
clinging to a hypothetical future until
we beat that into them
bex have you ever had
a moment where that was like difficult
for you where you saw her wanting
something and you knew it was the result
of outside influence you know it wasn't
like authentic desire absolutely yeah
yeah um
i try to walk this line with her
where
will we'll acknowledge the desire
and try to talk about where it's coming
from
um
and also helping her see
how
you know maybe her friend is
you know placing a
her desire to be close with her friend
is placing a greater influence on her
than her desire for something else
but um
one it's not directly related to this
but one of the things that came to mind
when we were first talking about this
question
um
was ella has this fascinating interest
in makeup
and i generally don't wear makeup
every now and then like today i'll i'll
put a little on and
try my best to look good on a camera but
um
yeah it it's not my baseline
i don't have an arsenal of makeup at
home it's not a a routine that we have
um
but she's very very interested in makeup
and for for several years now she she
regularly will ask for more makeup and a
couple years back i finally sat down
with her and talked with her more about
this interest and turns out
she
had made this really interesting
association between
her time that she got to spend with um
basically a stepmom type figure who she
was really close with they they had a
beautiful relationship um
and makeup she had a lot of makeup she
would put it on you know
with a routine every day or when they
were going you know she and uh ella's
dad were going out for dates things like
that and so ella got
to know
um
this woman named stephanie
and her association with makeup in sort
of a loving
caregiving type of way
and also as an art form
it's not how i use it at all
and
so it was able i was able to understand
better
where her interest in that was coming
from and that's a little different than
you know
uh
preschool classmates
um
but it it's kind of the same right like
it's sometimes our stuff is a way of
relating to other people and developing
social bonds
and so i think that sometimes especially
with little kids it's it's
talking about stuff or or bringing in
their you know their stuffed animals or
their you know favorite toys or whatever
is a way of
of helping them bond with each other so
it's not so much that they have you know
x number of items it's more like they
have these couple things that are really
important to them and instead of
moralizing those things hey too much
makeup is bad or wrong
we're not doing that but it's asking
questions and also helping her get
really practical yeah around some of
these things because understanding that
having
a hundred types of makeup all around
most of it is never getting used and it
becomes wasted yeah but if she has fewer
things that she wants to play around
with when she plays dress-up or whatever
then she can go to those things that are
her favorite things but if you have a
thousand things it's impossible to have
a thousand favorite things because they
become watered down
with excess yeah dk you had something
pithy here that you wrote down i thought
this was this was worth talking about
yeah um can i just quickly comment on
what bex just said please do okay i what
i love most about your your story there
is how much you learned about ella
you you learn something about the
connection that she feels to stephanie
and how much she looks up to her
and you learn something about her
appreciation of the creative process
right she's drawn to it not because she
thinks it makes her look beautiful she's
drawn to it because she likes the
intricacy of it and the the art of it
and that's a cool thing to appreciate
and how many other applications might
that have and you're in a better
position to be able to connect with her
to be able to anticipate her needs and
her influences just because you're able
to listen non-judgmentally so i really
love that and and that does lead me to
my my pythy thought uh which is when
you're free from pleasing all the people
you're free from needing all the things
there are always going to be people out
there who possess things that we don't
have who attribute status and praise to
those who have those things and as long
as you're attached to that stuff you'll
need all the stuff that brings it but we
have to liberate ourselves from needing
to be
a status holding person in other
people's eyes and how do we do that
i don't think you can make your child
want less things i don't think you can
make your child stop liking what they
like i think all you can do is help them
learn how to process their feelings help
them learn how to intimately connect
with the story of why behind the desire
and that's one of the greatest gifts
that you can give a human being because
that's going to help them with the
psychological declutter that will
precede the physical declutter you know
i imagine i think about my my nephews
who are pretty young right now where i
imagine if i had a son and you know
fell in love with some girl at school
that didn't like him back
and he came home to me and was like
i like this girl and i don't like her
that's a struggle because
my son likes someone
he's attracted to someone he feels
desire for someone and they don't feel
the same way and we so long to protect
our children from the reality of
scarcity the reality of you can't have
everything that you want or every
everyone that you love isn't gonna love
you back or feel the same way and
sometimes all you can do
is
simply be with them and help help them
process
yeah
you really like that girl huh
what you like about it
that's okay to talk about right it's not
gonna hurt what do you like about it
because the opposite is also true if you
want your kid to become a maximalist
simply
disallow
material possessions in your home and
it's going to make those things so much
more enticing our friend rob bell a
former pastor he says hey if you want to
get your kids to read the bible just
don't permit it in the house
that's right that's right and i think
the same is true with our material
possessions if you want a kid to be a
hoarder
discourage things tell them things are
bad or wrong that their desires are bad
because
that's going to draw them closer to
those material things as soon as
something becomes taboo
what do we do
we want to explore it we want more of it
it becomes a sort of kink in a way we
talk a lot on how to love about
different kinks and to avoid kink
shaming but as uh former podcast guest
dan savage talks about you actually want
a little bit of shame in the kink
because that's the thing that makes the
thing that adds the tension it makes it
exciting and so there's something about
our stuff the tension that we have with
our stuff or the tension we have with
our kids as well
that creates a dynamic through which we
grow it creates a little discomfort in
our relationships as well
because if you have three four five six
people in a household whereas a previous
caller had
eight people in the household right
well then there's going to always be
some bit of tension the key is that you
might not always be on
the same page but you want to be reading
from the same book
we got a bunch more segments to
talk about seven different simple living
segments coming up but first alabama
what do you got for us here's a
minimalist insight from one of our
listeners
hi my name is stephanie i am from
toronto ontario canada and i wanted to
just um
share a tool that has really been added
value to my life as somebody who is
going through grad school wanting to do
a phd and does need to kind of refer
back to
those those items and those notes uh
evernote is really great because you can
actually scan scanning party
scan all your items chapters from books
you know journal articles your notes et
cetera et cetera
and you can import them into evernote
and you can actually tag them
and
you can collaborate and share
your notebooks with uh colleagues and
stuff and what this does is like if you
want to go back in time and review kind
of
uh like something
you know that you need to reference you
can go right to your tags and all your
items that are under that particular
category
will show up and you can show all your
notes you can add to it you can
collaborate it's just a fantastic tool
if you want to move from keeping all
those books and keeping all those
references those reference sheets with
loose papers to a digital form it's
added a lot of value to my life and i'm
just sharing it with everybody else
all right before we get to our added
value segment this week let's thank
the beautiful rebecca sharon for being
here today yes ma'am
you can check out her podcast it is
called how to love you can find it on
apple podcast spotify google podcast or
wherever you listen to podcasts or if
you want to dive deep into some really
uncomfortable conversations with me and
bex i co-host the show with her you can
find that at patreon.com
how to love real quick for right here
right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists unfortunate news
we had to cancel our two canadian tour
stops we had these two canadian tour
stops that we rescheduled a couple times
but because of some travel restrictions
about half of our team would not be able
to get into the country right now
canadians i'm so sorry but don't worry
as soon as those restrictions are lifted
we'll reschedule these dates who knows
ryan and i have been to every province
throughout canada except pei we'll get
there one day we want to drag tk with us
as well so maybe this will be a great
excuse for us to expand the canadian
tour as soon as we are able to stay
tuned to our email newslist the
minimalists.com you'll be the first to
know
but also since we've been talking a lot
about kids today tk i wanted to throw
this out there
you've been talking to a lot of high
schools occasionally middle schools
colleges as well
and you've told me that you're willing
to go speak to certain schools for free
can you talk about that absolutely now
if it's nabisco or starbucks you gotta
pay me
[Laughter]
don't try to take advantage of the
minimalists and get me for free
um starbucks i mean burger king
especially after i defended the ads they
gotta pay me
no so i i talk with uh different high
schools uh usually one every month
and
my the program that i created is called
revolution of one and it's based on the
premise that the best way to create a
healthier and a freer society is by
starting with the individuals who
comprise it and you do that by teaching
people how to leverage the things that
exist within their locus of control how
to be the predominant creative forces in
their own lives how to start with their
own health their own mindset their own
work their own discipline their own
family their own relationships and how
to expand outward from there by learning
how to be a person of possibility within
that sphere and so i talk about all
sorts of topics from leadership
entrepreneurial thinking creativity and
problem solving and what i usually do is
i usually work with the teacher or
someone from that school
to talk a little bit about what sorts of
things are your students struggling with
because it's different for every every
group and what sorts of things do you
want them to walk out of there being
able to do and then i customize the
workshop and i go in and i talk to the
students so
because i have a limited amount of time
i can only do one of these a month and
so what i try to do is is maximize the
experience by saying you know try to get
as many students at one time as you can
together if you can get 50 100 students
together
you know for one opportunity
then i can come out there and we can
make that happen for free i don't have
to charge you for that this is part of
what i do um as the education director
at fee and so it's it's a labor of love
it's something that i'm really
passionate about and um i'm i'm enjoying
the privilege of seeing it positively
impact students so if you've got
students that you want to learn more
about you know the abundance mindset
entrepreneurial thinking overcoming
adversity whatever it may be
email me at podcast at
theminimalists.com
alabama we'll get that over to tk and
he'll work on the details with you what
a gift that would be if you were a high
school student or just any student to
have tk show up and talk about some of
these challenges that we are facing
right now
for added value segment this week
we got a few things to talk about
alabama's bringing me a stack of things
i'll still grab that
thank you so i have a a bunch of things
i want to oh man what do we got here oh
our friend
crosby taylor
danny you just met him the other day he
has a book out and beck's just made one
of the recipes from this it's called the
fit baker now he's probably the fittest
guy i know
and he also had a bunch of gut issues
similar to what i had he was trying to
figure out those gut issues by reducing
the nonsense that is in our diet the
pesticides the chemicals
the allergens etc etc and so in this
book
he takes a
simple approach to baking healthy
desserts and healthy foods in general
it's called the the fit baker you made
the blondies from here this past week
yup i think we ate all of them yes we
did hey wait wait wait wait wait how do
you make your blood that's my favorite
dessert ever really good i mean these
are delicious he even made them with he
made them different monk fruit or with
uh maple sugar
we made them with maple sugar because i
couldn't find monk fruit where we were
um but yeah you can make them with
with the monk fruit they're delicious
they were
the recipe was fantastic and it turned
out which
doesn't always happen with recipe
so our friend crosby taylor the fit
baker uh you can check out the book
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
he also we saw him at the grocery store
the other day and he just put out this
cookie mix
sugar-free gluten-free grain-free cookie
mix
monk fruit sweetened and then obviously
you just add your wet ingredients like
eggs butter or ghee or coconut oil
vanilla extract and i
have not opened this yet because i
wanted to show it on the podcast he
wouldn't let me open it i wanted to make
several of the cookie recipes in the
book it's like oh i want to make this
one i want to make that one but the
recipes in the book call for the mix
so
even though we had the mix i couldn't do
it so that's what's next you can check
it out we'll put a link to it in the
show notes the website is
crosbybakingco.com
you can also follow him at crosby taylor
or at crosby's baking
co
one of the things i got to return this
to the library we were talking about
this earlier on the private podcast we
were arguing about whether or not uh
people want to receive
penis pics
shut that discussion down really quickly
you were
building it up like we're gonna make tk
uncomfortable and he was pretty
uncomfortable i think tk shut down the
conversation no it actually seemed
uncomfortable it was it was 15 minutes
of conversation it was pretty expensive
for him that's a tweet that's tweet
length for tk if you keep it under 15
minutes brevity is uh is a
crutch for him you guys you both you
you both elaborated on
each side of the issue you did it all i
didn't have to participate at all which
is kind of funny given the topic this is
an amazing book it's like if don delillo
who i think writes the most beautiful
prose by the way this book is called
acts of service if you're not watching
the video version by lillian fishman
it's like if dondala who writes the most
beautiful prose wrote 50 shades of grey
but it's never gratuitous either it's
it's very
sensual it's sexual it is beautiful but
it's also playing with the dynamics the
emotional dynamics between men and women
women and women men and men and
understanding like oh there are a lot of
sort of cultural concepts around
well these topics that we were talking
about today i won't go too far into it
because i use that one of my how to
write better videos i teach bad writing
versus good writing this was certainly
one of the examples of good writing it's
one of the best novels i've read in a
long time it's called acts of service by
lillian fishman by the way we got a
bunch more surprise questions this week
on the private podcast like is it
possible to own more things than your
husband and still be a minimalist we'll
talk to bex about that we'll get tk's
thoughts on that as well how do two
residences work for a married couple
with kids well bex and i have kids and
we are married and we also have two
separate residences so we'll talk about
that plus we got a million more
questions for bex and the minimalists
and if you want to hear all that check
out the minimalist private podcast visit
the patreon.com or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
all of our archives recordings of live
events weekly home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you if you have a
question or comment for our podcast give
us a call 406-219-7839
or email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists to get our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus tk coleman rebecca schern
alabama podcast sean jordan no more
professor sean social jess danny unknown
post-production peter emma the immigrant
and the rest of our team i'm joshua
fields milburn if you leave here today
with just one message
please
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'd be fine
without it